a health fair in southern Guatemala
communities here suffer one of the
highest rates of malnutrition in the
world
government programs offering help are a
valuable resource
we are mainly focusing on medical
attention we provide Health Services
like parasite treatment and nutritional
assistance with the aim of preventing
disease
according to the UN food and nutrition
needs in Guatemala have reached historic
levels
authorities here in Guatemala say one of
the biggest challenges to combating
malnutrition is accessing rural areas
adding that the places that are most in
need are often the hardest to reach
the terrain in this part of the country
can be extreme but 17 year old Heidi
ishka hook makes short work of the Steep
paths that lead to her home
Heidi says that while government
assistance in the form of food resource
planning has benefited her family they
still lack some basic necessities like
clean water
water most of all we don't have potable
water fortunately there isn't a severe
water shortage here thank God for the
rain but it's still difficult at times
experts in Guatemala blame corruption as
one of the driving forces behind
worsening poverty which casts a shadow
of food insecurity over the country's
most vulnerable citizens
we've had three or four governments to
have plunged just deeper and deeper into
corruption money is being spent on
unnecessary things and we're neglecting
to invest in the most vital asset of
this country children so money is being
squandered while we're simultaneously
facing a nutritional crisis
Guatemala one in two minors suffers from
chronic malnutrition as the situation
worsens non-profit groups have stepped
up to provide assistance where
government efforts fall short
Child Care Specialists say without this
help the situation could deteriorate
further
[Music]
right now we're weighing and measuring
to see how the progress has been but I
do believe these children would be worse
off because at home there are many cases
where their diet consists of sugary
drinks things that don't do us any good
experts warn that without urgent action
from the next Presidential
Administration the country's poorest
communities have little hope for a
better nourished and more hopeful future
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Guatemala City